good evening and thanks for joining us
tonight at 11 o'clock I'm Sasha Loftus
California is not the only area seeing
severe weather right now this is from
the area of Virginia City Nevada that's
just south of Reno you can see water
flooding in many areas all across the
road there many roads are blocked off as
it becomes too dangerous for drivers to
get through now because of this severe
weather Governor Joe Lombardo has
amended the emergency declaration to
include nine additional counties this
would allow impacted areas to receive
state and federal assistance to protect
citizens and repair any damage the
current storm is expected to bring more
snowfall to the Sierras this evening